[Music]
in toldja
News sponsored by said no Jim ah now in
Rowland Heights mm-hmm mmm submitted by
Mexican fans from Oregon oh oh but I go
no Oregon oregano oh why did you put a
bee in there oh there's a state in
Mexico now I'm doubting myself no no how
do you say Oregon and Mexicans the job
Oregon Oregon what I going cuz you know
how like a lot of the West Coast State
Oregon are very ordered will espanol
what I go on a DS on that a man was
released from prison after investigators
found the dog his accuser said he'd
killed sounds confusing what I know it
so easy accuser and he said oh he's
accusers and I'm like I'm like yeah but
then they found a dog and it's not dead
oh my god he went to jail yep yikes
could you all Yanks you can go to jail
for killing a dog well that's not the
reason why this man went to jail
uh he was convicted of sexual abuse of a
minor and the person I saw this minor
who was saying that he sexually abused
said that he had threatened to shoot her
animals if she went to the police about
the molestation and she said that she
saw him shoot her dog killing it to make
his point and so he was saying I never
did this I didn't kill no dog you need
to find that dog to prove myself wait
yes I wanna [ __ ] you yeah I didn't kill
the dog
[ __ ] her really bad he said I [ __ ] her
yes but I didn't kill her dog he didn't
do that he didn't do any of it is what
he's saying well he was just saying if
you find the dog if you can prove that
she's lying which then proves that she's
lying about everything that's his point
yeah oh I thought it'd be funny that's
like he was like but I didn't kill that
but I would never kill a dog yeah yeah
yeah that'd be she did accuse him of
actually this whole thing is tied
together based off of the fact that she
said I saw him kill my dog yeah so then
the
prosecutors are saying well you know he
killed the dog so he must have also Vil
ested her so then that's why the other
the defendants or whatever they're
saying no you find the dog you'll see
that she's lying about everything
did he shoot the dog and he was wearing
a bulletproof vest no he's a police dog
so that's when he had the Innocence
Project so after he was convicted he
went to jail yeah oh that sucks too
because if he's really not a molester
they get [ __ ] up in jail oh yeah yeah
and it's just like I mean it could just
ruin and people in jail love dogs even
if you find out later that you weren't
like you you were guilted guilted found
II you're founded guilty go to town to
IRD thank you it's still it's still
[ __ ] ruined to reputation that's what
they say in the UK guilty found it today
yes it's a little bit different I said
filthy counted you mean like not guilty
and it found it not guilty just forgot
the I mean you found it sound like they
hear that you were found guilty you're
just you're just tarnished and it's like
yeah right you didn't do it get the [ __ ]
on Salvador car and you get it fixed it
looks pretty but it's still Salvage view
you're not found guilty though if you if
you get it cleared it sounds like
something yeah but she's just saying
that people still are like yeah right it
was still public knowledge and it was
gonna be them differently it sounds like
I would say though it's like they did
this and then they kill my dog like it's
like it's really actually went into the
house in a cheese string cheese yeah
it's like unrelated lies she's young
right she's like a real kid I don't know
her aides I would just say that it was a
minor oh okay it could be like someone
who just doesn't like the guy and wants
to send him away to prison or whatever
what would be sad is that like what if
he was a molester right and then she
just made up that other part to really
make it sing well we don't know yeah
support that if that is true then it
sucks because he got exonerated dude if
she lied about the dog she lied about
the other thing come on now nothing more
it could be what Joe said was she she's
just really trying to nail them you know
just try to tie all these things to him
I know but then the idea that then I'll
stick to him forever and it's an
unproven thing is like such a problem
that we have in society right now
just like that a guy who lost his future
being like a football player because the
girl put up yeah and he got convicted
for rape and then later DNA evidence
shows that he was innocent that was a
huge shock and he lost like most of his
life when you like a racial thing -
right I don't know about that oh that
was another the old old one from like
the 50's I mean yeah but there's a lot
of cases like that that's you can't come
back from that
yeah stick see once it's on you it's on
you and the sex ones those always stick
to you forever and ever
yeah because they're like well what if
they didn't look at everything and now
you're a sex offender for life and all
this [ __ ] so you think if Jared got
exonerated you can't come back and do
Quiznos no Quiznos would be smart though
it would be smart to hiring him we
always believed in Jerry like what are
you guys surprised about we've always
had really [ __ ] up mascot
remember that guy was like that queers
dog and he's like got one big eye it's
like we've always had really [ __ ]
strange weird mascots like I don't even
know they had mascots yeah they had
masks on yeah they had this like paper
bag who like had a [ __ ] weird eye and
he's like we love the SOB you remember
that [ __ ] yeah it was pretty is pretty
good I loved it that's how you make
Jared works yeah but he's not the
Verizon guy he's not that can you hear
me guys switch the [ __ ] no [ __ ]
loyalty I will always judge that guy you
went for Verizon to sprint right I can't
hear me any of the clouds on Verizon
shits all over Verizon we only got cable
to just watch come on so all this now
cuz they're dope yeah anyway so this do
that we're talking about here his name
is Joshua so six months after he was
convicted he asked the Oregon Innocence
Project for help and that's when they
were looking into finding this dog his
name is Lucy it's a black Labrador and
so they went all over the place trying
to find Lucy and they finally found her
which then again proved that the accuser
was saying was lying I was lying I mean
at least one thing here
so this how did they know because
they're saying that she had a very
distinct head and like I don't know
somehow they were meant to randomly find
a black lab in you know like out and
about I don't know if you have the
answer to this but what happened after
she said her dog died did she give it
away or like does she keep hiding the
dog or give it to a family member we
don't know the fact that she got rid of
the dog something and it's like oh
actually it's not dead oh that's such a
big missing piece my thought wasn't even
that I thought that the dog just ran
away and she just decided to use that as
you know fuel our ammunition to the
story that's just so hard to give away
at all I would be able to do it seems
like the easiest part of the whole
people are just crazy being on here it
just always reminds me that people are
crazy
I think about these stories for we don't
you know that people you don't know that
stuff people are crazy
I had no idea that one if someone's like
playing a trumpet at 3:00 a.m. in the
morning that's not crazy to you I
respect that that's creative yeah about
when you're driving you see like a
[ __ ] couch and like a ladder in the
middle of the freeway that's not crazy
that's someone's junk
I mean how'd it get there put that there
to tell us the story okay I see it's an
installation you know what I think what
makes this girl look even more guilty is
the fact that after Lucy was found she
failed to attend a meeting to discuss
her testimony oh so she felt at ease
upstairs and then when one of the
investigators heard that she was home
when he pulled up to the driveway she
ran away oh yeah in her own home when
you showed us the picture of the dog who
are the two people oh that was Josh and
his wife the cutest guy yeah the cute
guy and this is him after getting out of
prison he was awfully happy
which one's the dog you know yep you got
a real good I wonder I wonder myself hmm
I'll be so plenty of they just get any
black lab I mean you do hear stories
about like sociopaths and it's
definitely sociopathic young girls that
do stuff like that like have you guys um
read gone or watched gone through yeah
book they explain even further like she
was actually a sociopath who would like
hurt herself and frame other people just
because they get to thank you God exists
yeah it's real am i bad to believe that
if you if you do a false call and you
put someone in prison you should
actually go through the crime that you
claimed someone did to you know I love
that so if you claim rape right like and
then like you lied and then you sent
someone to prison and it finds out that
you lied to do this malicious thing I
think that person should be rape first
oh okay should go to prison for the
amount of time that you were gonna give
no I think I think you should do exactly
have you ever seen double jeopardy hell
yes you know the method ends up
happening she goes so the her husband
framed her as killing him yeah in a boat
and then she ends up going to prison all
this time and then they had a son
together and she gets out of prison and
then she finds out that he was alive the
whole time and did this whole thing with
her best friend and then she ends up
fighting him and then she had the
feeling objectionable you can't get
tried it that was booked that was back
in the good old days when women were hot
in prison and shows and movies damn
that's crazy in prison orange is the new
black room in that [ __ ] I mean here's
the thing if this person gets tried for
that crime like we were saying rather
than taking that extent it would likely
end up happening to them in prison
no but it should happen before Antigua
as a sentence yeah and they should have
a rape action where she's standing there
another auctioneer who are not do this
to her no I love the titles and I it
can't be pleasurable no no it's like
four guys and each one of their claims
are even more crazy like executioner
sold to the auctioneer what the guy
that's gonna rape or the cafe I love
that no matter what I'm doing in the
future there's always gonna be a video
with me where we discussed a rape option
this cool bar Crobat Crobat yeah Billy
have a baseball bat with the nails going
through it any other basil all a man
would corner over the [ __ ] Creed you
look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]